how do you put on a headscarf it's my
first time in Saudi Arabia in Riyadh
wearing a headscarf is mandatory entire
outfit 35 degrees outside is it you've
got adjusted to that right yeah because
it's really hot you know it's really
hard this is global a recruitment
company for Saudi women there is no
gender in a success it says right here
at a glow work but the strict
segregation of genders is one of the
biggest challenges to overcome even here
at a globe or females cannot mix with
the opposite sex you see here a man in
one room and women are separated working
in another room the founder of global
tells me separate workplaces were set up
for women to respect their privacy but
he says greater interaction would
actually improve the output the only
thing lacking is the social barrier the
communication gap between men and women
once that's over then we'll start seeing
more integration of women into the labor
market the agency is the first stop for
international visitors wanting to learn
women here Holly it proudly named some
foreign politicians this is Frank
Steinmeier who came to our office two
years back we have John McCain senator
the agency connects Saudi women with
retail consulting or manufacturing
companies and it wants to rebrand the
image of Saudi women don't ask us how
the woman that's living abroad
and says that she's suppressed and if
she cares about her country she would
come back and do something about it
because today is the time for change
Maha Alice man wants to be part of that
change she's one of the few willing to
show her face on camera something that's
traditionally considered indecent she's
24 an intern studying marketing I think
it's difficult for everyone whether
they're female or males so I mean it's
just because we're new to this and we're
trying to find jobs it's a cave I mean
it's it's the same I think I don't think
there is much difference but there is
one third of working-age Saudi women are
unemployed that's nearly 60
higher than the unemployment rate among
men the country can't afford that Saudi
Arabia's sudden focus on women is part
of vision 2030 a government plan to
create jobs in the private sector and
diversify the economy it can no longer
rely on oil revenues alone prices and
demand are volatile Saudi Arabia needs
to tap into new sectors like the service
industry tourism and technology I'm now
in Jeddah a city on the coast less
conservative than Riyadh it's more open
to change here I can take off my hat
scarf progress in Saudi Arabia tends to
happen here first take this taxi company
for example it wants to hire female
drivers though the ban on women driving
hasn't even been lifted yet I feel that
the change has been happening too fast
that no one is actually believing it you
know and what used to be like a tab oh
no no in the past is now just normal and
legal and just life so far every driving
here is male as of June women will
finally be allowed to drive themselves
at the beginning I used to like get a
lot of concerns from our male captains
they were like are we gonna shut down
you know it's you know 70% of our
customer base are women I don't think
that woman driving will really impact
the the right healing industry in Saudi
it's flourishing everywhere but
segregation is visible even in this
elevator for women only it's a question
of decency unmarried women are not
supposed to mix with men on the way to
my next stop of course I'm not allowed
to drive in Saudi Arabia woman's
independence depends largely on her male
Guardians willingness to relinquish
control my driver doesn't mind that
women will soon be allowed to drive it's
a good thing it's their decision if they
want to drive
maybe they need money would like to work
as a driver while traveling through the
kingdom I sense a lot of euphoria among
women pursuing independence and greater
self-determination
this is seventeen-year-old north she
wants to become a pilot one day for now
she's working in a food truck
her father encourages her to make her
own money and be independent how do you
think about the future for women in
Saudi Arabia the future will be good it
will be more equal between men and women
and women will be able to develop more
than men they've started to do some
really good things for women in me and
myself
we'll listen to some music do you like
it or it's strange do you like it or no
yeah listening to music in public that's
also new in Saudi Arabia it's only when
the camera is off that these women dare
to tell me that their level of freedom
still depends on their male chaperones